foreign
and our imaginings horrifiers
so oppenheimerite's core tells the story
of a chain reaction started by the
creation of the atomic bomb early on in
the film The sinus working on a worry
that's setting off a nuke might actually
set fire to the atmosphere and
inadvertently destroy us all this is
something that greatly worries articular
character upon the theory being posed
rushing out Albert Einstein with the
calculations he asks whether building
the bomb could kill us all and this is
something that comes full circle at the
end of the film now I have to say that
the movie left a major impression upon
me and upon leaving the theater its
final shot has stuck with me it's
haunting for a number of reasons and
throughout this video I want to discuss
why it's so impactful this will go over
the meaning of it the Thematic elements
in play and how it all comes together to
bring us the perfect ending heavy
spoilers ahead so if you haven't checked
out the movie then I highly recommend
that you check out now if you agree with
us then please hit the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe of videos
like this every day by the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the ending of Oppenheimer
[Music]
now the movie closes out with
Oppenheimer meeting with Albert Einstein
and they end up discussing what could
happen in the future it's a conversation
that's been teased throughout the film
and it's something that's also haunted a
character we'll talk about later on
Oppenheimer ends are being completely
rocked by it and he realizes that his
creation has now escaped his control now
what I love about the film is that once
he's built the bomb he becomes
absolutely powerless in stopping it from
being used now the cat's out the bag the
entire world will eventually get their
hands on it and it could potentially
lead to the destruction of our planet
now Oppenheimer is someone who has an
endearing personality and because of
this he's been able to win lots of
people around throughout the film he
watches people happily fall in line with
him and he very much showcases The Cult
of Personality this is in all aspects of
his life and we see it ranging across a
number of things that happen whether
it's the women he meets the Communist
Party the teacher Union meetings or Los
Alamos itself he's great at gaining
people who will follow right behind him
however Einstein correctly guesses that
this won't last for long and that the
government will use him up and then spit
him out he then predicts that they'll
eventually parade him around but it'll
be a self-serving way to give themselves
a pat on the back this is something that
happened in real life too with
Oppenheimer being ostracized before he
was welcomed back even recently Joe
Biden's Administration has overturned
the hearing decision and he's now seen
as someone who was a hero to his people
but it wasn't always the case and the
final film's hour sent us around showing
how people turned on him now I want to
discuss this all more in just a second
but firstly let's go over the final
shots and what they really signify with
Einstein the pair talk about that
initial chain reaction and Oppenheimer
realizes it may just be a delayed one
initially they thought the Trinity test
might wipe things out but the
destruction of the world might now be
inevitable Oppenheimer is seen as an
equivalent to Prometheus and now the
toothpastes out the tube you can't put
it back in as a student he watched rain
falling into puddles Sunny was plagued
with visions of things he didn't fully
understand how about come the end of the
film he finally gets his head around it
and knows that by building the bomb he
may have set us on a dark path as he
watches the rain hitting the pond this
then transforms into nuke sites and he
imagines watching missiles lighting up
the sky It's haunting stuff and to make
matters worse we none know that the
protests for a hydrogen bomb have fallen
on deaf ears the whole movie itself is
somewhat of a ticking time bomb and
those raindrops in the puddle have now
built up to this it brings everything
full circle from those opening moments
and shows a chain reaction will engulf
the entire planet all of this
destruction is based around the idea of
escalation which is something
thematically that builds throughout the
film though the Soviets are allies
there's always the idea that once they
have the nuke they might become the
enemy escalation is something that's
plagued every single conflict and it's
something that can be seen across the
entire Globe Nolan has talked about this
in his films before and it was something
that showed up in Batman Begins Gordon
argued that if police started carrying
knives that the criminals would then end
up having to carry guns this would then
lead to them having to buy Kevlar vest
which would lead to the criminals buying
armor-piercing rounds Batman was seen as
The Next Step Up which would lead to
mass criminals narrowing the streets and
that of course came in the form of the
Joker and in our world Batman is
basically the nuke now that America has
won the rest of the world will try and
at least match them but more times than
not they'll try and build bigger ones
this ends up eventually creating the
hydrogen bomb a far more devastating
explosive with even more power this
being out in the world could lead to
people trying to make a bigger one and
eventually will hit a point where we get
a world ending device now if you've ever
read Watchman you'll know a similar
thing happens there with Dr Manhattan
changing how Warfare is handled Russia
is jealous that the US had their own
Superman which causes them to stockpile
even more arms this leads into a cold
war that's about to go hard and you
wonder whether nukes being brought to
the table will lead to our destruction
looking at the film they actually have a
debate within it whether it's better to
just give the Soviets a plan so that
there's not a monopoly in the movie they
talk about the scientists Fuchs Who in
real life was the person that handed
over the secrets now looking at history
he actually got caught but he argued
that he did this for the right reasons
if you could say that the Russians
should have the bomb because it's at
least a way to help level the playing
field now whether you agree or disagree
is another thing entirely but this move
vastly changed how wars were fought from
this point onward we've mainly had cold
Wars where there's always a threat the
other side could fire back this keeps
our hands off the trege and instead of
there being nukes flying everywhere
Espionage in spying tends to be how
things are fought Oppenheimer says that
the atomic bomb should make it so we
never have to have a war again and there
is the argument that it de-escalated
things too now whether you agree or not
it is another debate but I actually
realize that Strauss somewhat represents
the Russian watching this you're
probably thinking what does he mean but
let's look at how the conversation with
Einstein is framed straw seas are going
on buddy isn't part of it and he starts
to suspect that oppenheimer's enemy this
creates a major Vendetta in him that he
then begins to use his way to discredit
and destroys reputation now this is all
caused by paranoia and fear because he
doesn't exactly know what's going on
with them they saw a country working on
making incredible advancements that they
themselves were not allowed to be a part
of ignore just like how Einstein ignored
Strauss they then put their plans in
place to take them down in covert ways
the secrets to the bomb were gain with
double agents and backhanded moves just
like what strass carries out on
Oppenheimer at the end of the movie it's
real that he manipulate everything and
he was very much Paramount and
oppenheimer's downfall he represents
someone who believes they can strike an
Act without repercussions which is also
what's symbolic of how the nuke is used
we never actually see them hitting that
targets and now I've seen complaints I
think this this strengthens the movie
everything's supposed to be shown From
oppenheimer's perspective and it shows
just how removed he is from the bomb's
usage I had Strauss overhead the Palm
conversation he would of course realize
it didn't have anything to do with him
still though this shows how paranoia and
fear can drive one to act in extremely
irrational ways he is very much the
salieri to Mozart but I think he also
represents the world's reaction to nukes
not knowing something causes them to go
using underhanded tactics and in the end
it creates even more tension knowing
Russia or being testing bombs causes
straws to look it up in high map even
though we know he wasn't complicit in
them getting them now to me the idea of
fear has played out perfectly in the end
with Oppenheimer being at the heart of
what he's created the entire film feels
like it's a runaway locomotive racing
away and able to be fully stopped Nolan
has stamps clicks and so on appearing in
the soundtrack and this gives the idea
that it's also like a train works really
well to build this final moment where he
realizes that he's no longer in the
driver's seat when meeting true men we
see that Oppenheimer is the only one who
really understands it but those with the
power to use it now don't really care
Oppenheimer says that he can't get the
blood of his hands which Truman sees as
meaning that he's weak in a complete
crybaby this is something that was
apparently said in real life as well and
it kind of shows the short-sightedness
that the leader had rather than seeing
what the bomb could lead to he was just
focused on having the power this is
something that Oppenheimer has Stripped
Away at the end and he's now going to be
used as a puppet in a pawn but standing
up against a hydrogen bomb he's gonna be
humiliated and once it obey Zaba he'll
be paraded around he's no longer got the
power that he once had and he's
Imagining the nuke's powerless to stop
them actually see lots of similarities
in Nolan himself who was of course taken
for granted by the studio Warner
Brothers he moved to Universal and has
now made a massive hit while that
companies hemorrhaging money left right
and center now when looking at why this
endings so devastating you have to
actually look at the man himself
Oppenheimer was just a professor at a
university and he ended up making
something that killed hundreds of
thousands of people he wasn't a
politician and he wasn't a soldier he
was just a man who had a fascination
with chemistry now he's become the
destroyer of worlds which is another
quote that I want to put focus on the
destruction of the entire world could
end up being next unless he stands at
the pond shaken by his imagination his
imagination is what plagued him as a
student but it's now gone far beyond his
deepest and darkest nightmares he's
created something that will forever be
applied on humanity and even today
there's still a worry of nukes being
used if you wait the pros and cons of
the bombs I think the negatives vastly
outweigh the positives and yeah there's
always going to be this worry that
they're going to be used as also the
debate over whether they should have
actually dropped the bomb in the first
place which further plays in the
oppenheimer's anxiety Germany had been
defeated and Japan was on his last leg
so which has made people debate over
whether the two should have been
detonated Oppenheimer realizes though
that these weapons are built to be used
and that Curiosity with the hydrogen
bomb may get the better of us so far
it's only ever been tested but if a
country ever got to the point of losing
a war then they might just fire one off
it's very very depressing to think about
and it definitely weighs on you as you
walk out the movie by saying that I love
this conversation that they have at the
pond because Einstein's the only person
that Oppenheimer can relate to he's the
only man in the science Community who
has the knowledge that he does and he's
the only other person who also has the
fame both stand at the pond helpless to
change the future before he walks away
just leaving Opie this is when all his
Visions come full circle from that
opening scene and he realizes the
Pandora's Box that he's just opened will
this weapon eventually lead to the
destruction of the world well I think
that's something that we're just gonna
have to see ever since caveman create
clubs Humanities build bigger and better
weapons and it won't be too long before
we advance on what we have that's what
the ending of Oppenheimer really means
and it still leaves me shaking that the
more that I think about it all in all
this is the kind of feeling that I want
to have on leaving a film and that's why
I think the ending of Oppenheimer is
perfect it's something that sticks with
you it's gonna change the way that you
look at the world and probably also make
you value the things that you have
around you hold your family tight
tonight it's a bit depressing but you
don't know what's gonna happen tomorrow
and yeah lots of things going on that I
think make this movie so impactful
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film so make sure you comment
below and let me know please drop a like
and if you want to support the channel
as a member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button because we
really appreciate it you'll get early
access to videos every single week and
it goes such a long way to helping us
out have you want something else to
watch we've got a full breakdown of
oppenheimer's Life which will be linked
on screen right now we go over his full
story in chronological order and also
talk about what happened after the
events of the film by the way huge thank
you for sitting through the video I've
been poor and I'll see you next time
take care peace